if we had to make one generalization
about why relationships fail it would be
this because people get defensive
defensiveness is behind a predominant
share of the failure of all
relationships
the difficulty is that there is no way
of escaping the sort of situations that
can trigger defensiveness however sweet
and fascinating two people might
initially be it is just inescapable that
they will also with time and the birth
of true intimacy stumble upon aspects of
one another's characters that can't help
but generate difficulties and a degree
of dismay
partner could be determined to be only
kind but the way that they shell an egg
leave the bathroom deal with their
suitcase on returning from a trip handle
the household keys or tell an anecdote
will gradually unleash powerful degrees
of frustration or puzzlement in those
who have to share their lives
a problem starts when we as partners
venture to air our responses our
partners might get very angry or they
might get very sad but the underlying
message from them to us will be the same
being found in some way imperfect is
entirely unacceptable and deeply
contrary to the spirit of true love love
me for who I am is the Fateful rallying
Cry of all lovers headed for
difficulties
because it is in reality a monstrously
unfair demand to be asked to be loved
just as we are given our panoply of
inevitable faults compulsions and
immaturities with a modicum of
self-awareness and honesty we should
only ever expect to be loved for who we
hope to be for who we are at our best
moments for the good that is in us in a
latent but not yet realized state
Spirit of true love should require that
whenever there is feedback we turn
gratefully to our partner and ask for
more that we continuously search to
access a better version of ourselves
that we see love as a sort of classroom
in which our lover can teach us one or
two things about who we should become
rather than a burrow in which our
existing errors can be endorsed and
ratified
a less defended attitude isn't a random
gift we begin to become less defensive
when we take on board some of the
following ideas
behind defensiveness there is always a
dread of being humiliated and abandoned
but a decent partner if we let them know
that we're afraid will be moved by our
tender desperation and Hasty fear and
they should help us to see that what
there is really to be afraid of now is
not criticism but an inability to accept
its gentle manifestations with Grace
if love really required an absence of
even the most minor flaws no one could
possibly qualify for a relationship yet
in reality we are love-worthy not
because we're perfect but because none
of us ever can be
in the defensive person's mind a tiny
comment is like the small rockfall that
announces an avalash there seems no way
to trust that it really is just about
how long pasta should be cooked or the
right way to make a bed the underlying
intention seems always to be to inflict
a devastating wound on us and speed the
entire relationship to a close the
defensive person has not had a chance to
experience the robustness of love how
it's wholly possible to call someone the
worst names in the dictionary and then
10 minutes later to want to lie softly
in their arms tenderness having been
renewed and reinvigorated by an
opportunity to purge a given frustration
they be ruptures and then repair true
love is resilient it's not destroyed by
a detail but only ever by the way that a
detail can't be acknowledged and
processed
defensiveness can be outgrown when
searching for a partner we need to look
out for someone who can join us in the
heroic quest to recognize and overcome
defensiveness
we might even raise this ambition on an
early date we might say I'd like one day
to move to the country learn Spanish and
maybe with a Lover's help get over my
defensiveness that's what we might
declare by way of introduction to our
goals
we could frame the attempt to listen to
criticism without Fury or hurt as
belonging to one of life's mightiest
challenges eventually with a lot of
effort we could hope to reach a stage
when a partner could point out with tact
and Humanity that we have bad breaths or
that our shoes don't match our top and
rather than reacting as we've grown up
to do we could simply turn to them smile
benignly and say what flawed human
beings should always respond with when
another member of the species deigns to
help them to grow into a better version
of themselves
thank you